there are rumors about uh cryptocurrency
have you heard of fedcoin yeah is it
what are they calling it fedcoin or what
are they calling it i don't think
they're calling it i think right where
clinics do but it's sbc i think uh
united states bank coin i think is
what's called yeah i don't know i don't
know off the top what the official term
is just like qe the fed never called
those programs qe that was like just
right wall street dubbed them if uh
when when we when we inflate our
currency when we pump out new dollars
and and stuff like that through
quantitative easing right so how does
that work okay so the the federal
reserve just buys assets electronically
and then in the act of doing that so
if the fed wants to buy a billion
dollars worth of mortgage-backed
securities it creates a check
then that check by law clears manifests
right because the the bank you know like
city citibank you know the seller of the
bonds deposits the check from the fed
and then citibank says to the fed we got
to check from you for a billion dollars
to this client and the fed says yep
that's good so the fed just adds a
billion dollars to the electronic de
balance citibank and then citibank adds
a billion to the deposit of that client
so just magically money is fake the
money supply went up by a billion
dollars and so when inflation comes
natural from that i have to imagine you
know china and other countries are like
hey yo what the hell because we have
debt and you're devaluing the debt we
have with you so they get pissed off
about that yeah it's
china and other you know big holders
they're in this weird position where
i think they want to diversify out of it
but yet if they just say to the world
you know we don't trust the dollar
anymore then it could crash it and so
it's a weird it's sort of like if bill
gates wanted to sell microsoft stock you
know he'd have to you know go through a
divorce or just divest himself because
of you know a charitable concerns there
was people say that's why i did it
correct me if i'm wrong but there was a
time when in order to expand the money
supply they had to find more gold
when they were making gold coins and
silver they were like if you don't have
the materials to make it you can't make
it
right so i'm sure everybody is vaguely
aware of the gold standard and how you
know nixon ended but actually to me the
the really cool period was origin you
know with the constitutional founding
you know late 1780s up through um the
silver right before the civil war
the u.s federal government did not issue
paper dollars
what they did is they said if you want
dollars you have to bring in a certain
amount of raw gold or silver and we will
stamp them at you know u.s mints into
coins that say you know twenty dollars
or one dollar if it's silver yeah and so
the public in a sense
determined the quantity of dollars in
existence
based on those legal rates you know they
announced the ratios basically like the
government was certifying this this was
a true and correct way exactly right so
the money the the money was gold and
silver and like that's how like mises
and other you know economists of the
time thought of it like they thought
money and so and so or sorry gold and
silver were the actual money and you're
right the government always the
constitution say that
right so it would it that's the thing
too like it gave the government the
authority to coin money it didn't mean
to print up fiat dollars it meant like
it was the same way like it could set
weights and measures so it could say
like 12 inches is a foot you know i mean
just to sort of to allow commerce to
flourish by having standard units this
is what we mean by a dollar it's this
many grains of gold so the fed right now
can simply say hey ian you got a billion
dollars and that's it here's a billion
dollars
yes but they wouldn't just give it to
them they would buy something for
because they're not done right if
they're going to get a billion dollars
give it to me though if i was a friend
of a friend or something they could buy
this crystal ball from you and say it's
a million dollar billion dollars and buy
it and acquire it and that's the way
they could funnel it to you what about
like my work like a nice jolly hellos
like i'm i'm now giving them some advice
and they can give me a billion dollars
for that
so economically there would be nothing
stopping i think there might be statutes
about you know they couldn't just pay
you for a service we would think that we
we talked about this on one show where
um i was buying uh i was i was buying
something from a bank
i had to do a wire transfer from one
bank to another
and then so i bought a truck we bought a
truck for our mobile production studio
and then one day i get a call from this
bank and i'm like they have no business
to call me because i settled that debt
but then eventually i decided to check
my messages and they're like we're
calling about an outstanding debt you
have so what happened was
bank a transfers money i said here's all
the information that was provided for me
and it was all true and correct they say
okay the wire transfer has been
initiated it should clear soon
the other bank that was supposed to
receive it said we never got it
we have never received that that wire
so then i'm like okay so i called my
bank and they're like no we have it
right here written down the money's gone
and i'm like then where's the money
they're like it's gone it just literally
doesn't exist
so
it how does this park episode no i mean
this literally happened to me a few
months ago if
the the banking system is literally just
one bank writing down a number and
saying you have it the other bank
writing down a number saying you don't
have it
and if one bank fails to write down a
number then the money is just gone
eventually i contacted somebody and they
told me you know they ignored me and
then i tweeted about it and that's
that's the magic word in today's you
know fascistic social dystopia where if
you've if you have enough followers you
can tweet your problems away right i'm
fortunate enough to have been able to
been like hey bank what's going on
where's my money and then immediately i
get like a liaison i'm like we're so
sorry mr pool we'll resolve this for you
and then they eventually said okay okay
we figured it out and don't worry about
it but the crazy thing is for a regular
person
if you have two banks and one bank says
we went into your bank and hit delete on
that
amount
it's gone you can't do anything about it
yeah i mean and there is in a very
legitimate or not legitimate that makes
it sound like it's okay
in a very real sense that like a bank
when it grants a mortgage to somebody
there is a sense in which you know m1 is
that is the term like that's the measure
of the money supply that that literally
went up like the way economists measure
how many dollars are in existence and so
the commercial banking system can expand
and contract the money supply through
lending when they order mistakes like in
your case yeah when they do loans
that money comes from nowhere right
right so i mean it's there's constraints
they can't just create a trillion
dollars like there's things that would
happen the reserves will get drained but
but yes strictly speaking there's
nothing in the accounting like when a
bank makes a loan it's qualitatively
different from like if if the bar or
something just gives you a drink and
puts it on your tab like there's a sense
in which they're creating more dollars
basically
you know ian says he wants to buy you
know my bottle of water
uh or you know this this bottle of water
so i say okay i'll give you a loan to
purchase it i as the bank then just
type in to the owner's account you have
a dollar and then ian owes me a dollar
but i never actually transferred a
dollar to anybody right
yeah yeah so maybe the way to think
about it is um
because remember we're talking about you
couldn't like use a treasury bond to go
to the grocery store you can go and buy
you know you can use a 20 bill like
federal reserve note right that's money
but you can also if the bill is 20 you
can take out your bank debit card and
swipe it
and technically what's happening is you
know bank of america let's say is saying
oh right now tim poole has whatever a
thousand dollars in his checking account
he swiped that so now we'll say he only
has 980
and we'll credit you you know uh kroger
whatever the grocery store is around
here an extra 20 in your checking
account yeah so you're right but that's
a checking account right but i'm saying
that no
they didn't need to do anything like
it's just on their computer
what i mean is if you so i what i've
been told is that when you use a credit
card right there's no actual transfer of
funds
the credit card swipe literally just
gives 20 to the other person's account
and then nothing is subtracted from
anywhere oh okay so sorry so where i was
going with it is to say so you can see
the grocery store does consider
what bank of america says as people like
how much money we owe if you showed up
and wanted your to empty your checking
account we would give it to you and
people treat that as as good as federal
reserve notes right so that's different
from just you know you giving him that
bottle of water and him saying i owe you
whatever ten dollars or whatever like
when when a loan is is given to somebody
that money is created
right and and the reason the reason
there's a distinction with what the
commercial banks do is because for
various reasons the merchants in the
community
treat
you know ilus from the banks as being
interchangeable or fungible with
federal reserve notes whereas most other
let's put credits they don't let's say a
a bank uh so it's it's what they can
they can lend out like nine times or 90
of their existing cash reserve
well that used to be the the fed got rid
of the reserve requirements so they're
so that particular thing is now
why did they do that they did when did
um it was
it was like in april it was right after
the coronavirus thing hit wow really and
they this is funny they they announced
it on us they announced it on a sunday
night and in the press release
you had to go read the follow-up like i
just said we've made some other changes
and you had to go read the follow-up
press release to see that they got rid
of reserve requirements in 2020. so does
that mean they can just literally create
money at any point for any reason okay
so that's what i was saying before so
there's no
statutory legal constraint on what they
can lend but there there is a mechanism
so
um if they lend out too much money you
know like people want to buy homes and
they'd lend a trillion dollars for
people to go buy homes people go and
write checks in there let's just i want
to make sure we're getting this clear is
what i'm trying to get at right i don't
understand
the bank isn't giving you money the loan
manifests the money upon signature like
the money is created at a thin air
for the loan's purpose
right
okay
so like basically the bank doesn't
doesn't
actually go to its coffers take a dollar
out of its piggy bank and hand it to you
they just write it on a piece of paper
they just they just poof a dollar's
there they they credit your account with
you want to go buy a car it's twenty
thousand dollars and you apply for a
loan so that expands the money supply by
twenty thousand right but i i don't want
your listeners to
uh take what i'm saying too far there
are constraints because if they're if
they're too reckless any one bank if it
expands too much when there's clearing
house transactions with other bank you
know so the car dealership that now you
deposit that check for 20 000 that was
created out of thin air electronically
that
dealerships if they have a different
bank when they go to settle up with your
bank they're not just going to say oh
bank of america is good for it they're
going to say send us federal reserve
notes or they're going to actually say
you know with your account with the fed
in our account the feds settle up with
us
so
there is a constraint ultimately that
it's called having reserves so the
commercial banks can't create federal
reserve notes and they can't compel the
fed to credit their own checking account
with the fed
so the fed can do whatever it wants
because there's there's no one above the
fed the fed just if it creates money
creates money period the commercial
banks there is a sense in which by
making a loan they do it but if they do
it too aggressively the chickens come
home is this intentionally confusing
yes and i'm sitting here trying to
decide how much detail to get into or
not because i don't want to say
something that taken out of context
sounds like i'm saying something wrong
but but yes there is a sense in which
they can create money commercial banks
do have limits the fed has no limit the
only limit yeah the only limit on the
fed is just price inflation gets too
high these local banks literally be like
i'm going to create a hundred dollar
bill for you ian so you can buy that you
know expensive champagne
yes there's nothing stopping them from
except if they do that too much so
that's the result that's money they
create when ian pays them back where
does that money go
so if they don't relend the funds out
that money gets destroyed and so that's
the sense in which the commercial banks
expand and contract credit and that's
why mises that was his theory of the
business cycle incidentally that the
commercial banking system they push down
interest rates expand credit causes a
boom
they chicken out for some reason they
raise interest rates contract credit the
supply of money in a very real sense
decreases and that causes a crash that
removal of the uh reserve requirements
sounds like the us dollar is worthless
and on the verge of imploding
so i i'm surprised more people didn't
notice it and make a big deal out of it
and it's part of the reason they didn't
is because since um the 2008 financial
crisis with all the rounds of qe
the as you you may know the banks were
just sitting on excess reserves like
they were they had money
pumped in by the fed and then they
didn't lend out like you said like the
10 times multiple they normally could
have
and so
when the fed got rid of those reserve
requirements it didn't change any of the
legal obligations in other words the
banks already were well above what the
requirements were so getting rid of the
reserves didn't constrain them but
you're right so some other countries
don't have reserve requirements too so
it's not like this is the one country
where that's the case yeah but it is
petro dollar country
yeah but it is um
right i i was alarmed by it like i said
the way the fed
they buying more bitcoin they did it on
a sunday night and they was under the
radar and and so the united they also
they also removed the limits on savings
accounts converting them into checking
accounts basically is that what happened
right yep
what does that mean exactly
you uh uh well you could explain it i'm
not gonna so they they made a change
where um i believe before it was if you
had it was technically a savings account
you could only move money from that in
your checking account six times
per month and they got rid of that rule
so that there's really in practice now
no distinction in checking and savings
accounts like basically so basically
savings were like considered not in the
money supply because you have a limit
six transactions per month from savings
to checking and it was supposed to be
that savings you know higher interest
and you put it in savings then they said
no more which means
all of a sudden the money supply
exploded and everyone's looking you've
seen the m1 money stock just skyrocket
everyone's like you got to understand
him it was funny they were like you're
misunderstanding this they're not it's
not an explosion in the money supply
they just change the way they describe
checking in savings and i'm like yo they
just said to extract your savings like
it's your checking
that is an explosion in the money supply
and it's
extremely bad news for this country
to to to to flat out say hey everybody
you know your savings start spending it
like it's all you got
it's basically them saying like oh yeah
we're imploding and you can take like a
million dollars in your checking account
at the end of the month move it into
savings get the interest and then move
it back
uh well if you did that you'd only get
it for the brief time you had it in
there you know what i mean but to your
so i'm that that's right so let me just
give you
my take on that so just for the people
listening
so m1 is one measure that includes
checking accounts but not saying it's
got m2 included savings accounts and so
you're right if you look at graphs
you know it's going along and then in
2020 all of a sudden m1 goes through the
roof
and so
people were alarmed and then you're
right the apologist for the fed was like
oh you right wing nut jobs whatever
you're always freaking out it's just a
statistical a redefinition yeah but even
if you've used the old definition m1
still went up a lot
you know what i mean so it's still at a
speeding angle speeding up like crazy
because m2 which the definition change
didn't affect also spikes and so i think
partly tim
maybe the reason they did that was to
have an excuse so people wouldn't be
panicked by the spike you know i can't
prove that obviously but it was
convenient that people like oh no when
it was like half the spike was because
the you know the money supply by any
definition really did
skyrocket we got it pulled up and you
can see like in uh around march of 2020
the straight spike just goes straight up
between from april to you know the month
of april is a straight line up and
they're like you know the rules were
changed and how we described things but
if you look after that
april 2020 until now
the difference between
before the spike and after before the
spike it's like this after the spike
it's like that i mean you guys can see
it you don't need to use my hand but
it's like it's slowly going up major
spike and then it's skyrocketing and
after the rule changes are you looking
at m1 yeah if you pull up m2 i don't
know if you're fret or what you're
looking at but m2 is not affected by the
definition change and so you can see m2
also spiked in april 2020 right show
this isn't just a definition they really
did pump in a bunch of money it's not as
pronounced in m2 but you can see there
is a spike and you can see that from
then till now
it is increasing the money supply is
increasing faster than it was beforehand
right so there's the one
shift like you're saying and the rate of
energy i didn't i didn't know about that
fraction that reserve restriction right
it was it was right all in the same time
period wow they started doing that if
they had known that i would have bought
way more bitcoin and also like the feds
started buying stocks you know like they
did a lot of stuff
because everyone's freaking out about
coronavirus and so the fed got paid
attention right wow
well i'm not going to give anyone
financial advice but i keep you know i'm
we've been expanding the business and my
attitude is like hire people you know
you know expand our facilities get more
equipment and people are like
you know don't you want to like
their questions about how fast we should
be trying to expand and what we should
be trying to build and i'm like look i'm
not going to sit around on this stuff
when inflation's as high as it as it is
we're like we had max kaiser on the show
and he said real inflation's probably
closer to 14
do you have any opinions on the
inflation rate in that capacity
i mean
this is anecdotal but when i go to the
grocery store now even and i'm not
talking whole foods i mean just like
walmart and whatever i can't get out of
there without spending two hundred
dollars i'm even buying me dude
we went to the grocery store the other
day and we filled up our cart and the
final bill was like 30 higher than it
was a few months ago and i was just like
whoa
and i'm like what i'm looking at the
receipt like what did what what happened
oh yeah but um
you know anyway and also they're doing
tricks too with like the packaging like
you're not getting as much cheerios in
your box as you're
the cardboard is is thinner if you've
noticed that like they're doing all
sorts of things right now i'm just
saying like the last thing i want to be
holding on to is us dollars
so i bought you know some crypto
where uh just
making sure that we're not sitting on
the money and we're expanding the
business it's like i don't want just
money singing the bank now we're gonna
make sure we have the right cameras all
right microphone microphones we're
looking at uh we just hired someone we
had another person today help us expand
and produce more content make things go
faster
there was a period in my life where i'm
like i'm i was always very much just
save save save now it's like get off
dollars we invest it in something else
we gotta be careful about hiring because
they're we're gonna need to pay them
more
eventually because the inflation isn't
gonna isn't gonna cap like the land that
you get or the cameras that's good but
and people next year are gonna be need
to be paid 20 or 30 percent and will
need to be paid more to cover their
costs too so i'm saying like
instead of just holding on to i mean uh
i don't know if this is did mines make a
public announcement recently i don't
want to say anything it's not public i
don't know i don't know to be honest
okay so yeah yeah
yeah so but but there's a lot of there's
a lot of companies that are announcing
um they're getting a fiat oh yeah yeah
25 percent is now
25 of their of their uh balance sheet
balance sheet is now in crypto wow i
think you're gonna see way more of that
and you know they're like china's
banning crypto i'm like shut up they
banned crypto every other month they
started a central [ __ ] they started a
cryptocurrency and then banned all the
other ones yep
nice
the us has got its plans for its you
know coin or whatever
i don't know i i don't think you know
all of these ultra millionaires and
billionaires who have bought into
bitcoin are planning on losing it
right especially overnight so whenever
these stories come out it's always the
poor people who sell off their
cryptocurrencies i'm not giving any
advice you do whatever you want to do
i'm just saying
the last thing i want to be sitting on
is is fiat currency we want to hold
things that will be good investments and
hedge against the cro like this is we're
we're in a death spiral as far as as far
as i can tell you just to clarify did
china actually they started a crypto
essential cryptocurrency i read that i
didn't yeah i didn't i didn't go deeply
into fact
i saw it someone was like that's why
they made it illegal
i don't know man what is what what's
without me without giving advice to
anybody just what are your personal
opinions on the state of the us dollar
sure so i i should uh admit this that i
i was very worried after the financial
crisis in 2008 and so i was you know
going around in my role like affiliate
with the mises institute and just in
general as an economist and i was
warning people about the stuff we were
talking about like how the banks create
you know fraction reserve and so forth
and i thought you were going to see
higher consumer price inflation earlier
and so i even you know i had a public
wager with another com and i lost that
and guys like paul krugman were running
victory laps making fun of me
so if you like you would mention
wikipedia my wikipedia entry it's like i
was born i lost that price inflation bet
and then you know maybe now i'll be on
temple's show that'll be the three
things that they they mentioned in my
life but um but in there i'm going to
say well i think the rest of the world
investors were just
misanticipating you know i mean like i
do think the dollar is going to crash
in our lifetime for sure i think it's
going to be a lot sooner than that just
because every time a crisis hits now
their solution is they throw
trillions of new dollars at it and so
unless they've stopped doing that you
know i think it's
like i said we've we've seen it now with
our own eyes like it it was kind of
weird then you know guys like me were
you know people were calling us chicken
littles and whatnot so i i sort of
was mute a bit about it for a while
because it did you know it didn't come
when i thought it was going to but at
this point clearly
prices are rising rapidly around the
country if last year
beginning last year you bought steel
chlorine cars computer chips
cryptocurrency
you'd be set for life i mean if you
bought bitcoin last year
like beginning of last year you said i'm
gonna put all my money in it
right now you would never have to work
again like the amount that it's gone up
since then is is absolutely insane have
you have you studied a debt recall at
all like the history of it over the the
millennia i think the ancient greece had
a debt recall
do you mean like where they just reset
everything is that you're saying i mean
i haven't studied the bible yeah where
they they're they're like bring us all
of your dangers and jubilee like every
50 years jubilee in the bible and stuff
yeah like is that what i mean inevitably
i'm looking at this like like it just is
like i'm staring at a big pink elephant
and it is that this fiat system is going
to crash
right so i
to me i think that's partly tied in with
this whole great reset and everything
like i think the people running the
system
know that they're
you know they're kind of pushing it to
the limit and that's why they're trying
to get ahead of it and you know this is
gonna happen and then they're gonna they
they have things in the wings that
they're gonna bring in to replace
the dollars is what i think ultimately
is gonna come down like they'll use
blackrock and then seize all blackrock
assets blackrock's assets and then
they'll have all the land and then
they'll start renting it out to people
for cheap or just for their slave labor
or something
i mean i don't know about those
particular details but but yes i i think
they they do want to move to a society
where
there's a few
you know multi-trillion at that point
dollar companies in league with powerful
states
and you know and they they kind of own
all the
real estate and whatnot and everybody
else is like a surf like we said and so
they're you know and then they probably
won't use us dollars at that point
yeah you get a little book you'll get an
app and the app will be like did you get
your loaf of bread this week
and then you'll like go to the store and
you'll skin
by the way to me another thing i see is
like they're trying to get everyone off
cash yeah and i mean just little things
like when i go to the atm now
the options it gives me for withdrawal
it only goes up to 200
i can still type in in a different
screen a bit more but 20 years ago it
offered 300 right now we just said like
that could go in one visit to the
grocery store so it's you would think it
would let you take out 700 right now is
it just a default option but it doesn't
so i think they're trying to wean people
off of holding cash and get everyone
just swiping cards because they can i
think that uh special interests
politicians
uh nonprofits want the labor shortage
it's forcing kiosks in self-checkout so
there's there's a big conversation about
you know how do we if we've got the
potential for kiosk ordering at fast
food restaurants right how do we
transition people out of these jobs
they're going to get mad when they lose
their jobs nobody wants luddite riots
right so what happens is hey look we got
this opportunity there's people are
freaking out let's now just start
switching all these things over to
self-checkout to self-service to kiosks
and then no one's going to plan on
losing their job because we're giving
them unemployment benefits right and
they're also that's the push for ubi and
everything that they're they're yeah
right i think they're trying to get the
public used to the idea that every month
you just get a check from the government
and then you're happy right and then you
sit at home and you communicate through
your screens and we regulate that flow
of information they'll be more miserable
than ever than they've ever been when
that happens thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.comcast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time